die stadt hat 20.000 einwohner und hier
soll sie leben die schwäbische hausfrau
deren sparsamkeit berühmt ist und durch
sparsamkeit sind die gerlinger auch
wohlhabend geworden spitze in baden
württemberg alle einwohner zusammen
haben jährlich eine halbe milliarde euro
für den konsum zur verfügung aber
luxusboutiquen fehlanzeige
der ort wirkt er bescheiden vielleicht
eine typisch schwäbische eigenart wir
fragen nach im heimatmuseum dass die
schwaben schon auch natürlich geld haben
und sich etwas leisten zum beispiel wenn
sie im pelzmantel haben das kaufen sie
sich schon auch aber dann tragen sie den
pelz halt ihnen und nicht aus dass man
es nicht sieht johannes eisele und hier
im museum treffen wir sie die
schwäbische hausfrau die sich die
südlichen länder zum vorbild nehmen
sollen
sie stellen gehen da die alarmschwelle
eher typisch schwäbische hausfrau wie
sich skater heuchemer
die wissenschaft ins geld seiner
hellgelb schaffe schaffe häusle baue nix
kommt nix kommt das gut an
das kommt sehr gut an freut sich die
quoten queen vor dem zielort ganz
deutschland ganz europa wahrscheinlich
sogar geld denn sie steht für solides
wirtschaften wenn es ums geld geht hört
der spaß auf
liebe vergeht hektar wie steht es ist
ein stück steht weißt du denn der junge
leicht ein kindererziehung nicht geben
sparsamkeit als lebenszweck so
funktioniert der ganze ort alle achten
aufs geld
das ist nicht weniger wird sondern sich
sogar vermehrt trotz euro-krise bei der
vermögensberatung in der bank weist man
das ganz genau
also diese gespräche führen wir fast
jeden tag dass die leute angst haben
hier
stellen wir auch momentan vermehrt fest
dass die leute die währung verlassen
also in den euro verlassen also richtung
norwegische krone aber auch
austral-dollar et cetera das thema
verstärkt verstärkt gerade momentan der
gerlinger packt an wenn es ernst wird
wir sind in der größten metzgerei des
ortes der chef zeigt uns seine letzte
größere investition eine fleisch
trocknungsanlage wie viel sie gekostet
hat verrät er natürlich nicht
eben typisch schwäbisch
ich denke schon das ist typisch
schwedisch das nur überlegt was sein
kann und dass es einigermaßen im rahmen
dessen ist was man leisten können dass
man nicht über seine leistung plant das
sich wohl glaube vielleicht ganz wichtig
sein betrieb hat vier verkaufs leben 50
mitarbeiter ein echter mittelständler
welchen ratschlag hat der unternehmer
für die verschuldeten euro-länder merkt
dass es bei uns eben nicht gut läuft
dann muss ich überlegen warum geht es
nicht gut und dann muss man die sache
anpacken und deshalb stehe nach wie vor
dazu hilfe ja aber der wille dass man
selber was auf die beine stellt muss da
sein auch im blick auf die ganze
südliche länder machen sie sich sorgen
um ihr erspartes eigentlich nicht mehr
hin
sehr viel im betrieb stecken und so viel
erspart das ist gar nicht darum was
würde das aber auch sonst sagen
diese mentalität für die auch die
schwäbische hausfrau steht stammt
übrigens aus dem neunzehnten jahrhundert
als die menschen hier sehr arm waren
heute geht es ihnen gut da sparen hat
sich gelohnt